[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais alors tu viens plus aux soirées
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya en fait une
drôle de tête
toi t'as l'air fatigué en ce moment tu
es sûr que ça va façon je te reconnais
plus taches orangées voici quelques
exemples de remarque peut nous être
adressées lorsque nous traversons un
burnout ou une dépression ou plus
largement lorsque nous sommes en proie
au stress à nos peurs à nos angoisses ou
à nos complexes
alors il ya deux ans de cela si on
m'avait demandé de vous parler des
problèmes sentimentaux
je vois sûrement pas su quoi dire et de
manière globale il me semblait que ce
genre de choses était réservé pour les
personnes de caractère négatif
pessimiste voire fataliste et j'étais
très loin de me douter ça pourrait
m'arriver à moi et pourtant et annonce
un an et demi de cela
j'aimerais bien traverser un burn out
qui fut suivi d'une dépression et un
travail complet de reconstruction
personnelle qui m'a amené ici devant
vous et au fil de mon expérience j'ai pu
me rendre compte que rares sont les
personnes qui savent mettre des mots ou
une définition sur les problèmes de
santé mentaux et lorsqu elles le savent
elles ne le font pas pourquoi et bien
tout ça
ce qu'un problème santé mentale ça ne se
voit pas alors lorsque j'ai commencé à
me sentir à aller un peu mieux je me
suis dit si je pouvais avoir un jour
l'occasion aider n'importe qui à mieux
savoir reconnaître comprendre ou traiter
un problème santé mentale mineurs tels
que la dépression burn out dans mon cas
et bien alors mon expérience n'aurait
pas été seulement utile à moi mais aussi
à d'autres et c'est pour ça le chien
aujourd'hui avoue compter mon histoire
immersion dans 3 2 1 c'est parti
septembre 2016 je quitte ma bretagne
natale après 3 en classe préparatoire
pour intégrer une école d'ingénieurs que
je convoitais depuis longtemps on me
décrit à cette époque comme une personne
toujours de bonne humeur
ultra sociable déterminée est toujours
motivé à apprendre et découvrir des
choses ce trait de caractère m'a permis
dans les cinq mois qui ont suivi de
d'être élu président d'une association
de devenir membre actif d'une seconde et
j'ai dû en parallèle trouver un job
étudiant afin de remplir mes fins de
mois
je me suis fait nouveaux amis j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un j'ai découvert la
relation à distance avec mes amis de
longue date et ma famille le tout en
poursuivant mes études d'ingénieur
alors autant vous dire que pendant cette
période là une journée type commence à
ressembler à peu près à sa bulle 8
heures à 18 heures des cours et de 18h
entre 22 heures et 3 heures du matin en
moyenne des associations ou des soirées
étudiantes
alors bien sûr ce rythme là ils étaient
extrêmement extrêmement à la fois
physiquement et mentalement mais malgré
tout je continue à positiver à me dire
ben c'est une expérience parmi tant
d'autres il faut qu'on en retire tous
les bienfaits possibles
voilà c'est pas grave jusqu'à ce qu'en
janvier 2017
certains de mes proches me fasse me
rendre compte qu'il ne visait pas aussi
bien que moi cette expérience que je me
forçais finalement à bien vivre j'ai
donc à cette époque-là perdu plusieurs
amis de longue date la personne que je
fréquentais et je n'ai rien trouvé de
vraiment mieux en fait que les cannois
qu'ont suivie que de terminer ce que
j'avais commencé
j'ai donc continué avec ce rythme là
jusqu'en ma 2017 date à laquelle l'année
scolaire les associations étudiantes se
terminer alors arriver là vous pourriez
me dire bah voilà c'est terminé
t'as plus qu'à tourner la page et aller
de l'avant mais ça c'est sans compter
sur la définition du burn out about
qu'est ce que c'est par traduction
littérale
on parle de brûler à l'extérieur de
manière implicite il s'agirait plutôt de
brûler jusqu'au bout et on y associe
souvent les termes d'épuisement de
saturation on parle de burn out au
travail ou de bernard parental dans le
manga et pour imager image un peu la
chose je dirais qu'il s'est agit plutôt
comme si mon cerveau ne trouvait plus à
cette place dans ma tête j'avais dépassé
le ratio acceptable entre énergies
disponibles les tâches à effectuer est
arrivé donc en mai 2010 est même si tout
s'est arrêté j'étais atteint d'une
fatigue physique et mentale absolument
écrasante et c'est ça qui a été la
source la graine de ce qui a suivi à
savoir la dépression dépression qu'est
ce que c'est en sus visées sur internet
vous ne trouverez pas de définition
exacte ou plusieurs et je suis mal tombé
sur le terme suivant troubles
psychiatriques a lancé vécu suite à la
suite à un événement grave on va être
qui s'installe encore une fois dans mon
cas et pour faire simple je résumerais
qu'il a s'agit d'une prise d'habitude
négative de pensées négatives en faisons
un petit retour sur cette période là de
septembre 2016 à mai 2010 7,9 mois 9
mois c'est le temps pendant lequel
j'avais habitués mon cerveau a pensé
très vite et à plein de choses en même
temps
et que fait un cerveau le jour il n'a
plus rien sur quoi s'occuper eh bien ils
jugent ils imaginent ils interprètent
ils renaissent et c'est ce qu'a fait mon
cerveau pendant les cinq mois qui ont
suivi donc pendant cette dépression cake
s'est passé en deux phases première
phase j'ai rejeté sur les autres
la situation dans laquelle je me
trouvais je me suis remédier à cette
époque mais c'est pas possible
moi j'ai toujours voulu tout bien faire
comment on peut en vouloir à quelqu'un
de toujours vouloir tout faire bien et
au bout d'un mois deux mois je me suis
assez vite rendu compte que finalement
la situation dans laquelle j'étais était
le résultat d'une somme de choix que
j'avais fait ou que je n'avais pas fait
et donc cette situation finalement ne me
revenait qu'à moi seul et donc pendant
cette période là j'ai pu vivre certains
symptômes qui sont souvent associés aux
preuves sentimentaux avec dans l'ordre
d'apparition est d'importance une
impression de fatigue constante et
permanente une perte de confiance totale
en moins on les autres en l'avenir une
incapacité à sociabiliser aller vers les
autres
une perte dans villa peu près tout une
peur du monde qui m'entoure et un
estomac crisper une gorge serrée des
problèmes d'alimentation on vous fait le
show de froid des tremblements des
problèmes de respiration allaitement
suffocation ou apnées du sommeil des
nausées et l'envié d'en finir
alors arrivé en octobre 2017
je me suis dit que pour ma propre
sécurité il était temps que je fasse un
choix
ces choix il s'est déroulé de la manière
suivante à droite
je continuerai de me morfondre dans des
habitudes néfastes dont il me serait de
plus en plus compliqué de sortir à
gauche je relevais la dette
j'apprenais de mes erreurs j'accepte
émetteurs et je faisais le souhait de
changer ses habitudes de pensée
alors autant vous dire que si je suis
ici devant vous c'est que j'ai fais le
choix de m'en sortir
et donc à partir de là je me suis promis
à moi-même que je serai absolument tout
ce que je pouvais changer ses habitudes
de pensée quel que soit le temps que
cela prendrait alors comment je me suis
prise partir d'autres d'octobre à l'as
eupen 2010 est donc je suis passé par
une première phase il s'agit de
détourner mes pensées je me suis dit
comme le problème sont tes pensées et
bien fais quelque chose je me suis mise
à faire des choses qui sont couramment
lire regarder des séries cuisine et
écouter de la musique
chose que je ne faisais plus depuis
assez longtemps mais qui se font partout
autour de moi donc au départ impossible
pour moi de lire plus de cinq pages d'un
roman vikings sans partir ailleurs
impossible
je suis très vite retrouvé à enchaîner
les livres en tous genres et je me
rendais compte que dès que j'étais pas
dans l'action eh ben j'ai pensé elle
était toujours là avec les symptômes
qu'ils accompagnent donc arrivé en
décembre 2017 je me suis dis bien
peut-être que c'est que tu vas avoir
besoin de chercher de l'aide à
l'extérieur donc j'ai pris rendez vous
chez un psychiatre
je me suis rendu et j'ai attendu et j'ai
hâte de rue j'ai attendu parce qu'en
fait il n'est jamais venu bon ça c'est
pour la petite anecdote en janvier qu'il
sourit vous avez loi moi j'aurais y est
déjà à l'époque j'aurais toujours
aujourd'hui car il s'est avéré que nous
sommes vus par la suite puis revue est
en fait suivi j'ai trouvé que même au
bout d'un mois et symptômes était
toujours trop présent et donc c'est pour
ça que au bout de deux mois donc en
février dernier je me suis inscrite dans
une formation de mindfulness ammann
foulé ce qu'est ce que c'est pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas et bien la main
de funès et un travail de conscience
conscience de swat ces pensées de son
corps de son environnement et du moment
présent
alors là il s'agissait plus seulement de
détourner mes pensées sur une action
présente qui me demandait pas trop
d'énergie mais bien d'y faire face
et mieux savoir les accepter voire
peut-être de le ralentir avec un peu de
chance on m'a par exemple demandé de me
concentrer sur ma respiration pareil au
départ impossible de me concentrer plus
du temps d'une respiration
inspiration expiration
non mais attends j'ai encore çà çà çà çà
à faire mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
m'avait inspiration expiration
j'aurais jamais dû dire ça comme ça ce
matin mais pour qui il va prendre quoi
inspiration expiration inspiration
expiration
ça a l'air facile comme ça j'aurais bien
vous y voir ailleurs je vais proposer
une chose là que ce soit à vous qui
regardez la vidéo ou à vous qui êtes
dans la salle je vous demande de vous
lever à tous parce que de toute manière
ça va passer votre après-midi l'acier
alors profitez-en
je remercie de jouer le jeu une fois
debout je vous demande et de placer une
main sur votre abdomen et l'autre dans
le bas de votre dos et alors vous allez
prendre grande inspiration les mains ou
s'écarter
tu physiquement logique et respiration
elles vont se rapprocher
je vous invite est maintenant fermé les
yeux et je voulais c'est une vingtaine
de secondes même pas vous vous
concentrez sur ce mouvement sont ces
partis
et je vais vous inviter à rouvrir les
yeux avoue rasseoir sur vos sièges et je
vais poser la question suivante qui dans
la salle a réussi à ne penser absolument
casser demain qu'ils s'écartaient l'une
de l'autre qui se rapprochait pouvait
lever la main ouais super bravo je pense
qu'on peut les applaudir merci à tous
d'avoir participé aussi bien alors vous
vous le voyez peut-être pas mais le nom
de main levée dans cette salle ça a pas
représenter la moitié de la salle
bon alors là bien sûr on est devant des
conditions un peu spécial savoir que
voilà vous êtes dans une salle aux
tadjiks si super super et coustous
flancs ce qui me regarde à côté ce qu'il
a fermé les yeux
mais voilà donc je vous invite à re
faire cet exercice chez vous et à
observer à quel point notre tendance à
partir très vite dans notre to do list
ou dans n'importe quelle chose qui peut
attirer notre notre attention néanmoins
au bout de quatre mois de genre
d'exercice j'étais capable de me
concentrer pendant à peu près toute la
durée de la séance qui durait en moyenne
une heure j'avais plus seulement donc
détourner mes pensées négatives sur une
action présente mais j'avais réussi à me
faire face en juin dernier je suis parti
en stage en écosse du nord et là bas
j'ai eu la chance d'être employé par un
laboratoire qui n'était absolument pas
la pression sur les lieux et les
horaires de travail
du manque de réussite et bien fait j'ai
pu rencontrer des personnes absolument
admirable forgé par de long hiver sombre
et froid qui les rendent à présente les
unes aux autres et enfin j'ai pu pour
payer mes loyers et d une petite dame de
72 ans à des tâches manuelles telles que
le simple fait de jardiner pendant cinq
heures d'affilée devant des couchers de
soleil en couper le souffle qui
scintillait sur une mer d'huile
le tout recouvert d'une petite colline
verdoyante et de quelques éoliennes
bon je peux vous dire qu'au bout de deux
mois dans ce dans cet environnement
j'avais plus seulement réussi à
détourner mes pensées à y faire face
mais je les avais également beaucoup
calmé
dernière chose à laquelle j'ai dû faire
face récemment en août dernier
finalement assez proches
ça a été de revenir faire face à tout ce
qui était relié à cette période là que
j'avais passé je suis rentré en france
j'ai revu ma famille je suis venu à
grenoble j'ai revu mes amis je passais
des egm à des examens écrits et j'ai
revu tous ces visages qui m'avaient
accompagné pendant cette expérience là
que jean de vous conter elle a dansé en
étant il a fallu que j'apprenne délier
toutes ces expériences qui était devenu
finalement négative du passé de manière
à ce qu'elle devienne positive
alors aujourd'hui je pourrais pas vous
dire tout ça est terminé
ce serait vous mentir et me mentir à la
fois néanmoins si on considérait une
crise de panique on angoisse comme une
petite boule de neige qui dévale la
pente d'une montagne pour devenir pôle
indiana jones pour laquelle il faudrait
se lever de sa terrasse en bord de
montagne pour l'arrêter à temps et bien
je vous dirais qu'il ya un ange mais je
me levais à peu près jamais ma chaise
longue
aujourd'hui il m'arrive d'en laisser
passer mais je me lève quasiment tout le
temps et je compte bien finir par me
lever à chaque fois pour l'arrêter ce
que je vois aussi c'est qu'il ya un an
jour pour jour à cette même heure ce
même jour je devais être dans mon lit
sûrement cacher sous ma couette
j'ai passé la plupart du temps à
angoisser souvent à pleurer j'étais
incapable d'aller en soirée j'étais là
où l'auvent tous les matins pour aller
en cours
et j'avais peur d'à peu près tout ce qui
m'entourait alors qu'aujourd'hui je suis
content de rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes
je repars en soirée j'ai changé mon pote
mon mode de vie et je suis même capable
de me tenir devant sur une scène devant
une centaine d'inconnus
ainsi je voulais qu'on retienne 3 chose
de statique seraient les suivantes
premièrement ne sous-estimé pas
l'implicite ce n'est pas parce que les
problèmes sentimentaux ne soit pas
qu'ils ne sont pas là malheureusement
deuxièmement arrêtons d'en faire un
tabou je ne parle pas de tous sombrer
dans la panique mais bien du fait que la
panique est due à une peur de l'inconnu
je pense que si on en parlait plus
souvent et bien le connaître et mieux et
si on reconnaît c'est mieux et bien le
comprendre et mieux et si on comprenait
mieux et bien on le traiterait mieux et
c'est ça qui m'intéresse et enfin si
cela vous arrive vous si ça arrive à
quelqu'un que vous connaissez et bien ne
lâchez rien ne lâchez rien parce que
nous n'avons pas conscience des
capacités qu'à notre cerveau à pouvoir
changer une habitude à répétition et
répétitions et répétitions et c'est ce
que je fais tous les jours
presque tous les jours je me
dans un milieu un jeu me dit estelle n'a
aucune raison de ne pas avoir confiance
en toi
tous les jours je me dis que tout va
bien tous les jours je me rappelle
toutes les chances que j'ai et tous les
jours ben j'y crois un peu plus alors
bien sûr ça peut sembler un peu nu riant
comme ça me convient à chacun de trouver
ce qui lui convient et j'aimerais
terminer en niant un fait qui semble
acquis dans sa globalité dans notre
société aujourd'hui qu'elle suivant la
vraie force c'est pas de se taire c'est
bien d'en parler je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]